you might be thinking this is a mod
but it's not a glitch to turn breath of
the wild into a first person shooter has
recently been discovered and allows you
to explore hyrule in the first person
and it works really well almost too well
it even works with motion controls to
simulate vr
and honestly i wonder why nintendo
didn't add this option to toggle on and
off with the vr update
i don't personally have the toy con vr
kit but i'm a guy for the switch onto
another vr headset and it blew me away
if you want to try this for yourself at
home then watch this video but i warn
you
this is hard to do like really hard and
requires you to have some experience
with breath of the wild glitches
but if you are curious about how it all
works there's some gameplay at the time
stamp here so you can just see what it's
like in action for more breath of the
wild make sure to like this video and
subscribe to the channel
to play breath of the wild in the first
person you'll need to do four pretty
advanced glitches
i'll perform these and show you how to
do it step by step without too much
explanation on why
so you can simply follow these
instructions without needing too much
fluff
first you'll need five multi-shot bows
shock arrows
any shield the camera rune the master
cycle
and a horse you're going to need them to
perform a menu overload
item hold smuggling and a model teleport
then
head to this kind of structure that have
stairs that wrap around the sides
i personally recommend this structure
here as it has the most success with
other players and myself
park your master cycle and your horse
like so then
equip shock arrows pull out your bow in
your hands then perform the menu
overload by going into the menu and
dropping the bow and repeat five times
it should overload the menu making link
lose some features
once you have successfully overloaded
then you want to item smuggle
this parts pretty easy simply hold any
item then unpause and check if link is
holding anything
if he is holding something you'll want
to hold an additional bow in your hands
to overload the menu just a tad more
until he has nothing in his hands
[Music]
now you're ready for the next part and
this is where it gets hard
[Music]
[Music]
mount the horse like so park it with his
back legs raised up against the curb of
the stairs
and aim it at about where i am on screen
now hold zl then hold x to ready
yourself
then slide your thumb over to hold x and
a at the same time
then release x this will immediately
shield jump off the horse
as soon as you jump off immediately tilt
back on the left stick and start mashing
d-pad
left i know it's a lot but if you see my
on-camera example it should help a bit
you may get weird jumps but you're
specifically looking for this leftward
tilt on the screen
no other angle works so far so keep
retrying as necessary
you want to keep pushing the d-pad until
you have the specific angle
now you're ready for the next part
unequip your shield then release the
d-pad and immediately pause as fast
as possible you're now looking for where
link is placed during the pause screen
now
usually you'll still see him upside down
so to progress to the next frame
hit the minus button then minus the plus
as fast as humanly possible
this is a trick to progress the game one
frame at a time you're looking
specifically for a frame that link has
disappeared
this is the frame that link's quote
unquote soul has left the frame and now
you need to item smuggle
hold the item and voila if link turned
invisible you're almost there
toss the item into the master cycle and
you've done it this
is called a super hold smuggling state
the item should now be floating in front
of link somewhat
strangely the best part about this trick
is now it'll stay with you throughout
your playthrough
so even if you die save load a file you
don't need to worry about redoing
this entire thing over if you want to
turn this glitch off simply fuel up your
master cycle
cook some food or just close your game
now comes the last part this is the
first person glitch
and this is fairly easy hold an item
then press a to toss it on the ground
even though it'll just float away
then go to your camera rune hold your
shield in front of you then press
l and left stick at the same time to get
rid of the cursor you want to pause
hold an item unpause re-pause then press
x to unhold your items
congratulations you're finally ready to
play but beware there are multiple
actions that will take you out of first
person mode such as jumping
running mounting paragliding and
attacking which is a bummer but
personally it took me back to the days
of n64 goldeneye where
jumping and running wasn't really an
option anyways if you did get out of
first person at least you don't have to
do the first three steps again
just this first person camera portion
[Music]
what you can do here is shoot a bow and
arrow throw weapons
boomerangs use wands master sword beams
use the menu to switch weapons and get
buffs crouch
crouch jump and even parry if you just
want to see some cool gameplay with it
here's some first person shooter like
gameplay with a speed boost buff and the
fastest bow in the game
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
from
yes
yes
yes
[Music]
so
hey
so
uh
[Music]
uh
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
you